hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control sc.l
2-3.13.13 control and monitor the use of
mobile code
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's dive in
here okay first thing to figure out is
what is mobile code great question
well I've got an answer why do I talk to
myself I don't know sometimes it's more
fun when it feels like there's multiple
people in my head mobile code is uh in
this sense is code such as Flash and
JavaScript that can be moved from system
to system and run without compiling this
makes scripts and these languages much
more dangerous and vulnerable because
there is no compiling necessary it just
runs on execution which is why it is
very popular and attacks so what's the
solvency here two items antivirus or
endpoint Management systems are often
built to manage the risk and then of
course firewalls that have advanced
packet filtering anti-virus and other
security features built in we'll scan
this kind of code on its way into the
network and recognize it as risky or
vulnerable in most cases for an exact
answer let's dive into what the
assessors are looking for on this one
two things they're looking for one
determine if use of mobile code is
controlled in other words do you have
firewall policies or anti-virus policies
that are controlling what can be used
when Etc so uh our sample answer is
mobile code is controlled via firewall
policies and endpoint management system
policies again in your endpoint
management system you're usually going
to find antivirus second assessment
Point determine if use of mobile code is
monitored I would say this implemented
firewall and endpoint management system
logs are ingested into the same solution
for monitoring that's right we're gonna
need our seam system to come on in on
this control so we can determine if the
use of mobile code is actually monitored
yes that's what's going to send you the
alerts
so hey and on call we work with defense
contractor just like you to figure this
stuff out because when you've had this
defar's nist itar and cmmc compliant
stuff dropped into your lap like I see
you on a sunny day we teach you how to
level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links that'll allow you to
get help right now
don't wait six to 18 months to get this
thing solved you need to solve right now
and that's where we come in if you love
the content we're putting out here for
you help us out with a big thumbs up on
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance service roll it out or if you
want the Easy Button just give us a call
or visit one of our links in in the bio
below visit one of our websites and
self-schedule some time with one of our
amazing certified compliance Engineers
calls free never cost anything anything
to find out how we can help and it might
just save you the next six to 24 months
until the next compliance tip my friend
stay safe and secure out there and hit
us in the comments below to let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]